today we're going to start a wall fairy
we're talking about more theory that's
called totalitarianism and we're
spending two weeks on this and this is a
major moral theory and you might ask why
did you put it off until the end of the
semester then dr. Stadler well because
historically it comes later the virtue
of a Hobson's contract hearing ethics
yeah things like egoism or what we call
the floret area so those have always
been with us you can look at any
primitive society and then any society
that has a literary tradition and a
higher developed you know civilization
and you can find something for the
advocating and everybody ought to get
what's good for that and forget
everybody else or we're saying you know
well where was it charged they get to
decide what's right and wrong and then
every society that develops a literary
tradition I think you can find something
sort of like Aruba they don't come right
now to call it a virtue necessarily but
you can find it cross-culturally Tillett
Arianism you can actually find ideas
like this not just in the last but also
say in Chinese philosophy
way back in the day you can also find
some sort of precursors of this being
Western philosophy but to make it into
natural moral theory that has its own
name and sort of tradition to them to
that that's still going on very strong
today that didn't happen until the
modern era and we're going to talk about
this guy Jeremy Bentham first he's not
the only important utilitarian there's
also Jon Stewart
we're gonna look at next week
carry them over Thanksgiving break and
then there were some other important
ones who were not gonna study like Henry
Sidgwick
the energetically contemporary
philosopher Peter Singer I don't know if
any of you've heard of him he's kind of
a famous guy we can talk a little bit
about him if we have some time he's
actually been just down the road at the
culinary because he does a lot of things
so if utilitarianism is a major
philosophy and we'll look at all of us
at rates but before we do that it's a
little bit of review think about when
each moral theory that you can come on
over we're going to go through the list
of the ones we know you can think of
what does it space moral ideal what is
the thing that really makes them tick
think about when you're finished with
this course and you're done here at
Marist and you graduate and you go on to
whatever job you're going to what are
you going to carry with you well when it
comes to moral theories how much of it
are you think to remember what are you
going to remember are you gonna remember
that you know pH 76
John Stuart Mill said X Y Z probably not
right you're gonna remember certain
ideas and knowing what the highest or
most important to think of values the
most idea for a philosophy that's pretty
useful
so what are some of the world theories
that we talked about us how was the
planet brought a new spin to it do you
remember remember what that was is that
this is a virtue ethics but it's also
another
I don't remember - there could be better
names for this I just picked
authoritarian because acid Authority
through Symmachus you might consider
Hobbes to be along those lines although
Hobbes also in another whether ethical
theories have you guys and if you
remember back to book through the
Republic there was some discussion of
something sort of like well we get
together I mean you know rules and
agreements
it's my contract what else yeah yeah
egoism we still have a active a republic
and Hobbes seems to start there
Aristotle treats something like that do
you know why I like or theorist
discussed legalism there's always
egoists right it's a sort of basic human
and starting point how many of you have
ever babysat or you know like had to
wash your little brother or sister the
attitude of the kid is essentially
egoistic what's mine is mine what's
yours is mine too whether a certain age
and then we try to get them to come out
of that some kids doing some kids don't
carry the materia ethics contract Irina
egoism we're living anything Alex Oh
Thomas was natural all right and then we
also have this thing did you have any
like oil it down into one or two verbs
you got this cheese purchase okay so
what's the opposite of aversion and if
you want it to be you know very pithy
and prosaic with this and putting it in
very short terms be virtuous don't be
vicious you want to be virtuous look at
what virtuous people do don't want to be
vicious don't act like those people over
there you know when it comes to say
specific virtues like generosity look at
the way generous people actually make
their decisions and I start modeling
their decisions after theirs if you had
to boil down this this sort of notion
after Symmachus and authoritarianism
into a few words
this is how you'll tell whether you're
retaining this yeah yeah I think that's
just fine I mean its trademark phrase
it's you know and I think that does
capture it for my face right so in moral
norms what's right and wrong or good and
bad ultimately comes down to us from
some authorities so you know if you
don't like the way that it's set up get
getting yourself in charge so you can
write from one contract here it is one
single phrase or an idea try to boil
that down and I understand it is
oversimplifying if you're locked into
social agreement saying like okay we're
gonna agree to get along
and what's the worst thing you could
possibly do go to social contract theory
break the contract
yeah because if you do everybody think
of cops right there are some versions
where it's not quite so nature of bloody
and tooth and claw or nasty brutish and
short
what you do is you have some that happen
phrase I had a fight
look out for number one who's number one
I you are after the ego this I'm number
one if I do natural log here this is a
little tougher as that's a nice easy
quick statement
let's pass over that actually you know
let's put something else we do ok yeah
that's right
how would we make Dennis that tough to
do it let me replace natural walk with
another one that we talked about here
and there we didn't get to look at one
of the main representatives I'm curious
keep this hedonism says the pleasure is
maybe eat drink and be merry
what about divine Dampier what's good is
what God tells you is good with bad God
tells me the bad the key thing to do
then seems to be to figure out what God
actually wants assuming of course which
icon a Christian culture right they said
Muslim the culture Hindu culture we've
all seen these WWJD bracelets offer
stickers and fluid necessarily what
would Jesus do give me what would Jesus
command
well when Jesus say you have to do now
you know I suppose you could say well he
did say at some point do the things that
I'm doing
bring divine command make it more broad
you can just be like these are all
things that you could easily say
somebody asked to what's what's virtue
ethics you know three years from now I
hope that you remember virtues and vices
right if you only remember one thing
from it that's what to carry it forth
because that'll that can help you
remember other things or this might
makes right you're gonna come across
that you're going to come across all of
these in the workplace if you go
guaranteed some people will be operated
with one moral theory some people be
operating with another some people will
be kind of conflicted and next up about
it you may actually be able to bring
some illumination to it so what about
utilitarianism
well utilitarianism actually has its own
sort of catchphrase by the time that we
get to to this point in time people have
savvy to that and it gets talked about
in terms of the greatest happiness and
we add to that overall so what's really
distinctive about utilitarianism we want
to talk about the broad sense is it
looks at whatever community is being
discussed presented and it asks what's
good for the community overall but
wouldn't ask that an asset about the
individual what's good see it where the
where this community you know there's
six ten seventeen there's a twenty-one
21 students one professor is so twenty
two people in here what's best for these
twenty two people overall now we could
find some things that are good for the
majority of us but I could for some
minority evenly balanced as far as men
and women the biggest imbalance in the
class of course be students professors
one one professor there's 21 students if
I was a consistent utilitarian which I'm
not but that was that one of the things
that I want to do is structure my
classes
structure this classroom itself so that
it promotes the greatest happiness
overall so that each each one of you
would count just as much as me that
another problem yeah we would try to set
things up so that even if it would make
me idea it would make you guys happy or
at least the majority we have like for
instance you know what are some things
that professors do what they want to get
on your good side they try to cut
classes down from skip a class like last
Thursday or something really professors
would actually come to an arrangement
with the students and say yeah we're
going to get out fifteen minutes early
every class everybody's okay and then
why are they okay with it well because
you know that's more enjoyable right and
especially the persons of really boring
lecture you you might actually be doing
the students a favor them right
sometimes people show a lot of movies
students like watching movies professors
like watching movies too you know why
not only do we enjoy the same things as
the rest of here what else why
professors you just have to say well
these principles that we've been
studying are illustrated in the matrix
or whatever I'd like you to devote your
attention to the screen in front of you
in the back if it's an easy day for you
what else I could maybe somebody to
suggest this earlier the semester should
bring Donuts well you did the idea right
I could make you guys really happy by
doing certain things well it might not
actually be the best things but it
really depends on what outlook you're
taking what is the goal here what
constitutes the greatest Hamptons that's
sort of catchphrase now let's actually
explore that I'm gonna raise
why can i erase you this one will turn
isms variety Kings
so but you're reading through your
Bentham you remember the very first
thing that he said is flowery phrase you
know mankind is two masters pleasure and
pain
well let's tells you what he thinks is
most important and we've talked a lot
about moral values over the course of
the semester and different Goods
different bad things utilitarianism is
type of he doesn't it says that pleasure
is be good pain is the so everything
that we think is good or evil really
comes down to certain kinds of pleasure
and pain and a higher balance of
pleasure against pain is what we think
of as goodness higher talents of pain
versus pleasure is what we think of as
badness for or evil that's what I'm
eating this was committed in a way is
kind of you can think of it as an
unmasking philosophy it's sort of saying
all these great high ideals that you say
that are more important than fighter why
are you into those what do you get out
of those what do you see in them a
different kind of pleasure how many for
instance of how many of you like reading
books you read books for their own sake
not just you know because you're
assigned that's pretty good now if I ask
you why do you read those books
yeah say entertainment okay
entertainment is I think the kind of
pleasure so you know for instance I I
actually like reading philosophy postive
I became a philosophy professor you
might now alright and there's certain
philosophy books I want to read things
for fun
I read science fiction or fantasy or
some classic novels you know I like
plays a lot but I do that because they
buy me pleasure do I get anything more
out of them
yeah if you're a good reader all I think
all of you encountered this there's for
every one of you
there's some book that you've read that
you connected with and it changed your
life in some way
the ferrets say one just because you had
so much fun reading it at times of wow
this really great story I can't wait to
find out the end there was some idea
there something that it may not have
been a little soft there was something
that you latched on to some thought you
carry the 4th Hermann you've mulled it
over if we expand this to swans and to
movies and TV shows and sitting around
you know chewing the fat with your
friends there have been some ideas in
your lifetime the captivated and they're
gonna be more that's the good news
were you just engage with them because
they were Pleasant somebody like a
virtue ethicist would say no you engage
with these ideas because they awoke the
human
they made you feel some way more alive
because your your rationality your mind
is part of who you are if you found
something getting a woken it you some
idea is spilling forth and you you know
you like that you thought there was
something good you weren't just doing it
because it was pleasant like drinking
coffee or drinking beer
laying in a nice warm bed probably
capitalist rather you doing right or
laying out the nice warm silence on
bathing or pick whatever other kinds of
pleasures you want playing with ideas is
not really that kind of pleasure but
could it still just be a hydrogen player
or a fine kind of putter
I think sometimes a pleasure you have to
look at the end result
not necessarily mmm what you've done we
go up to that point okay that's a good
point and that's actually going to take
us forward a little bit so a pleasure is
the good there's lots of different kinds
of pleasures and we can compare them
against each other
like for instance would I if you asked
me which do you prefer more can't have
both of these would you prefer to read
the Marist student newspaper of the
circle who copies on there available or
drink some some nice coffee quite
frankly today I would say I'd rather
drink the coffee there's other days
where I would I would rather you know
become well informed I don't know let's
go again
I'm canvas but today's
there's certain pleasures there or you
know we could compare pains against each
other right
would you rather have the pain burning
your finger or feel the pain
threading down those commercials we see
those starving children well they're
both kinds of pain TV that if you change
the channel well you could recover
quicker from that you have more control
over okay let me cover from it rather
than the paper your burn or something
like that yes that's to notice what's
going on you're making distinctions
you're saying here's why this would be a
worse pain here's why this was not this
better we're certain characteristics
let's go back to one of the things we
said got pleasure and pain all different
ranges has good bad things right and you
could actually balance them off against
each other you can say hey would you
accept this amount of pleasure if this
amount of pain comes with it yeah or
will you do this if week and all this
pain okay you know I'll go to the
dentist but I'm not going to get my
teeth drool
I suppose if it got really defined a
toothache I got really really bad and I
was in terrible pain and the dentist
didn't have any novocaine I might say go
ahead and drill but it would have to be
pretty bad for me to get to that point I
imagined the rest of your probably like
that's it so we have all these different
kinds of pleasures okay then we have
things that are not by themselves
necessarily pleasure pleasurable or
painful but then leave pleasure right in
this piece of troffers yeah does anybody
good pleasure a truck by itself like the
taste or beautiful bit your hand or you
know the sound it makes when we drop it
there cracks on the floor this is good
Brittany pleasure all right
can you think of any ways it possibly do
that I could think of a whole bunch
something I'm kind of in kind of silly
like you know let's say you didn't like
somebody you could write something on
board about that so so is they did you
draw a picture too you know that would
if you really don't want somebody never
bring you pleasure or maybe you'd bring
you pleasure to the you know draw a nice
mural before people come into class with
that students do this and then he come
in and people say ha that's really
that's really nice and they don't even
know that it's you
you know that sort of joy and heart work
being highly regarded that can bring
pleasure for this bringing pain in any
way no so what is they know what did he
swallowed it and how did it bring you
pleasure were you know you're you're
running in the holiday except I poke
yourself in the eye with a be a lot of
tape this doesn't have any pleasure or
pain in it
by itself it's what it could lead to
right there's a lot of things out there
we've talked about money before right
there's money you have any intrinsic
value why do you want money
yeah it's good for stuff how many how
many do you feel better when you have a
lot of money here now all of you do
surprise all the most of these yeah
because you realize that that money can
bring you pleasure or healthy through
avoid pain now this ability to produce
pleasure or this likelihood or tendency
to produce pleasure is where we get
utility rhiness latarian because utility
is
to reduce or remove pink so this being
in this class have any utility for you
it may not actually have it may not
actually bring me a lot of pleasure
right now is there a purpose for you to
be in this class looked at this question
before what is your reason for have
nothing better to do that o'clock Monday
mornings you may have said yeah I always
wanted to know a little bit about ethics
but that's probably a secondary
consideration hopefully by the end of
the semester that's become a primary
consideration but this class is useful
for some and actually is graduating I
suppose you'll also pleasure when you
graduate right walk across the stage
parents are there the rest your family
you'll feel what having something that's
that's pleasure so this has some utility
right and with a lot of things in life
you can ask yourself that they have
positive utility or I guess you could
say negative utility as well when you
make decisions you're gonna buy you do
quash do you ever do a cost-benefit
analysis or like a future you guys know
to teach others the pros and cons
probably been doing that since you were
a kid is your parents going to do it you
know to try to teach you you know
responsibilities
like that or maybe your teachers did
well what you're doing in there is
something very similar to utilitarianism
but what your ultimate ly basing it on
our pleasures and pains if your
utilitarian so think about any given
thing that you do during a week what are
some of the things you make decisions
about well surely have to practice how
do you decide whether to take off a day
or maybe visit by the coach doesn't want
me you know you're an adult right
what sort of decision-making process
goes up I'm sure there's some days where
you say
use this as an example you have a
decision to make
no practice or some crap
and if in practice you have to figure
out what else you would do in that
situation skip practice and go to bed
skip practice what else might you do so
let's get Christ some days you just want
to sleep right what else might eat
itself you might actually say I'm going
to skip practice I better make it worth
my while I'm going out what do you want
to put it okay
so we have three different options now
what we would do if we read it so
latarian says we start looking at things
in terms of pleasures and pains and we
would do this first or for one of the
people who's affected which would be you
this is your decision-making
once we're going to sort of planners
would there be in going to practice
make sure that our athlete are better at
your position I said maybe improve your
role as a team maybe like a leadership
role or something I mean you can't get
any better in sport actually doing it
right it's like musical instrument you
buy a guitar and it's hard sits there
you're not going to become a guitarist
actually learning a musical instrument a
lot of really blind nothing the boring
stuff this and quite the skills of
learning all these chords and finger
positions and athletics is a lot like
you have to do you don't scrimmage
anything else you think one of their
pleasures what about games yeah if it's
a good practice you are going to be sore
afterwards actually I didn't feel
terrible during the middle of the
practice you might fall out what else if
it's a pretty physical sport so we'd
like clock you accident
you can have a purpose well this is in
order to keep this really simple we'll
just go to this okay so what am I going
to bet many things involved in bed for a
buck if you're at bed long enough to do
pen sports coach could have consequences
oh there could be a pain right
see
I remember one time they should run a
lot and was doing a lot of training for
different things friend of mine you
hundred ten mile run
there was like middle of summer by the
time that we were done to the house
we slept for like you know we actually
laid on the floor and I remember waking
up when she came home but it felt so
good laying there out of the floor that
was intense pleasure right you might
some of this might transfer right the
coach comes down out here especially if
you know the coach sees you two off that
darvey's or something like that
what are you doing where are you in
practice today you're not gonna get that
source review I have it there do some
other
that happen with this impossible things
make it fight even without meaning to do
it could be the terrible car accident
possible you'll probably I'm assuming
doing out beings what like drinking
going at a bar or something like she
would probably be well even the since
you're talking about sleeping and like
the morning activity so if you're like
walking but you would say well there's
you contemplating sleep again or getting
up early to go out people have it tended
classroom no this is like after after
class festival after class afternoon are
you gonna go to practice like you're
supposed to ready to say I'm going to
get enough or are you gonna maybe do
what they call pregame a lot of people
do they do it just that's negative why
do people go out and go to these waters
socialize with friends
okay so socializing that's action if
you're right anthem talks about he talks
about the pleasures of conviviality what
else
why do people drink other than once
we're addicted and you know now I have
to do it daily or else they don't
function
there's a physical pleasure right come
with that so there's some physical
pleasures and some people they don't
drink the things that they need they
drink because they like to taste to them
they have all sorts of gourmet beers
there's a million different types of
wine other people like you know other
than other things now with each of these
do you think that you could assign some
sort of value to them like a numerical
value Bentham talks about a couple
different things that would have to go
into this one would be intensity right
are some of these pleasures more intense
than others or sort of some of the pains
more intense than others like bed sores
but I'm willing to bet that it's pretty
painful
I've been hungover and that can be
mildly paying for that could be terribly
painful depending on how much coach
coming down on you I can be painful
or something like that but you know say
feeling like you're losing the respect
of somebody Razak respect that contain
the soreness that you feel afterwards I
think you know physical pain
how many together like that
now they didn't used to do this but what
do they do now with pain they ask you
say a scale of one to ten how painful is
this what they're doing is they're
asking you to evaluate the intensity of
the pain they don't say because the
Robin pain is a burning pain or
something like that they want to know
the numerical value because they need to
know how bad it is really do you think
you could could evaluate pleasures
against each other and maybe come up
with a scale what do you think think
about all the different letters you
experienced what would you say is really
a really intense pleasure it could be
physical could be psychological what's
the most pleasant thing you've ever
experienced
the team a new goal yeah the sort of
satisfaction that happens with with like
everything coming together that can be
very pleasing people you know that can
be so pleasurable people can get
addicted to that yeah winning a game
especially it's a close game really good
opponent and you flow through and again
that that I've experienced this when
you're on a team and somehow there's
those moments where everybody seems to
be like on the same page and you can
just see things happening that feels
really really good that happens what
happens music - whether you're playing
with other musicians and
could you rate foods against each other
how many eat in the cafeteria here only
a few we can't examine I'm going to get
across the street little restaurants run
threats to be read oh okay what do you
guys like tea
chicken parm okay okay that's how many
people in here like chicken parmesan
okay that provides us a useful put it
compares really good at chicken
parmigiana what's really done really
well I like that you know it's boiled
too much so chicken primary that's
really good pasta let's see how to scale
of 1 to 10
we're going to put that we don't if you
want to do the Attila Tyrion sort of
thing you can't fool you have to start
calculating how intense pleasure so
there's other things too what about the
duration what about time some pleasures
last longer and some pleasures don't
last forever so the chicken parmesan how
long does that last
it's yeah you probably eat slower than I
do
yeah baby not even last step what are
some more lasting pleasures things that
will stick with you for a while good
meal that's interesting a good meal is
one of those few products where it's art
its artistic production is designed to
be destroyed and it's not destroyed to
do his job
it's designed to no longer exist we're
going to go really well how many of you
buy music how many of you have bought
music in the last month or so do you
save yourself do you buy that music I'm
okay with only having this this at p3 or
do you read music anybody in here no why
something that if you like listen to it
you can the one listen to over and over
again yeah maybe not fax back but later
on you're going to hear it again so you
can't have the same chicken parmesan
once but you can listen to the same song
people do this they first buy a CD and
there's one side they like they play it
over it over and over again why did way
they can do that yeah that pleasure
continues for a long time what would be
some other pleasures that could continue
no longer about this making progress in
something physical or psychological
older that's a long-standing pleasure
that would make a pleasure more valuable
wouldn't so intensity duration what else
comes in there what else is important I
bet them actually tells us about this
certainty or uncertainty talk about the
bed stories thing right not likely
you're going to get bed sores from
sleeping in one day it could happen
there's a very slim outside chance you
can also fall out of bed if you're in a
funk by the top think of course so on
you would reduce a lot of pain but these
are not great likelihood I'm going out
some things are pretty certain if you
drink too much you are going to be
hungover
that's just physical
having a good time most people go to
bars drink to meet people and is that
something that you can bat I only happen
we're gonna go to the bar and you're
definitely gonna meet something but you
have to be a date she's nothin gonna
meet your here is that a certain
absolutely if you go out you can you say
hi to somebody and talk to somebody
you're gonna meet them oh yeah but I
think we absolutely think the view to
get it past the point of a short
conversation it's to make no connection
yeah it's not as guaranteed as going out
and being able to get drunk
true yeah I mean though the being able
to go out the drunk that's pretty
service ones we've got money in their
wallet and you don't you know get the
bouncers name that yours yeah being able
to meet somebody pick anywhere you want
that's not as predictable and that could
be a really great pleasure having a
great relationship and I'll cross all
these things that would encompass a lot
of funders relationships also be the
source of great pains to it right when
they go bad they can cover the entire
spectrum with any given relationship
you could probably get some sort of
assessment okay you do this in real life
when you say I don't think this is going
anywhere or this is the one you're
making a kind of redemption and if
you're ready to latarian that person was
the one it's because they bring you a
greater pleasure than they do pain
that's the way you make your decision
Bentham talks about some characteristics
of pleasures to that we could think
about but what I want to get out the
most is we've looked at how something
might affect one person so far the
Tillett arianism is different than
playing hedonism the cheapness would say
okay do that sort of calculation figure
out what your pleasures are where the
pains are but you don't have to take
other people necessarily into
consideration do you I mean how many of
you care about what other people think
the rest of you don't care what other
people think okay let's see how they
feel how they're affected by your
actions now that I think probably all of
you care about what other people think
do you ever feel pain because somebody
thinks badly of you
like if you did actually did something
bad and then people you know they don't
trust you because you can understand
that right but if you didn't do anything
bad and they just don't like you and
they won't give you a chance that's
gonna make you feel worse right with
utilitarianism other people's pleasures
and pains matter as much as your own
with hedonism you only care about other
people's pleasures and pains insofar as
they affect you so really you don't care
what other people think you don't take
them into consideration as a hedonist if
it does bother you that other people
think badly of you or it does make you
feel good other people think well more
friendship is you know something
important to you as this then you would
actually take stock of other people for
you to a free to latarian the taking a
broader perspective you say wow we're
going to look at everybody affected so
think about different kinds of
communities families right if a parent
is transferred or gets a job offer that
requires up the move to different state
and yeah so who would that be spouse is
and let's say well this being transfers
now what you would do is you would look
at the pleasures and pains that are
going to resolve for each one of these
people and let's say we're going to sort
of assign arbitrary numbers just to make
it very very simple we were really good
what we're supposed to do is utilitarian
we go through this Wong step-by-step
process but Wilma is going to get a
great job opportunity I'm going to move
up in position so let's say it's we're
somehow quantifying the pleasure it's
worth fifty heathens now how far would
this affect the other spouse
could be positive maybe there's more
jobs for them then so let's take a lot
of calm but let's actually say this
let's assume and now it's not completely
certain somewhere I could get as high in
value and let's say it's like plus and
they didn't really like living in the
Hudson Valley
Bobby and Suzi have a lot of friends
here and this is where they go to school
this is what they're used to experience
it and Texas is pretty hot summer and
Houston is not so let's say Bobby and
Suzi are really really upset by this
well what does this tell you that woman
shouldn't take the job
yeah now if we start tweaking this we
say well we'll find each of you a
situation Playstations
right right
okay so right now they don't have their
own rooms Bobby and Suzi action show
we're just you know getting kind of
inconvenient start sweeping the be a
little late for tea still always the
positive benefits together sponsors you
should still say don't go right because
you're considering the entire you can
keep in touch with in on Facebook
yeah what if we watch you each and
iPhone so you could test them it's
tilted to the other way isn't it
now imagine this on a larger scale think
about political decisions think about
any contentious topic that retired Mike
Brinson should the one of the one of the
things that's on the table right now
because the Obama administration again
because of the Occupy movements should
the the upper class pay more taxes let's
actually think about this in terms of
the different people involved obviously
you want to tax them they're gonna be
affected right
who do they want to stick it to all the
rich people so that's not be asked
people middle-class most people actually
think they're middle class level
demographic if they're not well let's
say that that's actually the truth that
sixty
and you're going to place greater burden
what do you think would be a good number
we're going to make this again really
really over simple this is not the way
taxes actually work we're going to
pretend that it actually is just like
taking directly from the upper class and
we'll be a good round number to tax
dollars so we're going to be pretty
upset
that's a lot of displeasure to them
because that's a lot of stuff that they
can't buy and maybe they were counting
on that lifestyle and it's kind of hard
to conceive of but you know people do
one things to stay the same and we're
gonna have rich spread it out and we'll
give a little bit of milk laughs like
say we'll get each person to the middle
class
lower-class I probably do maybe five
thousand a lot of this money I mean if
you look at it like logically you know
the parks you know welfare you know and
so there's a transfer of money and then
these these other people are benefiting
in other ways too from all the parks
infrastructure all that sort of stuff
and let's say that's actually worth to
them something like let's say if the
government provides a really lavish
benefits I mean if you're gonna you're
going to take a million blocks from each
of the top 1% that'd be an awful lot of
money and you can do an awful lot with
it and so it's not unreasonable that you
might actually be able to provide now
notice there's only 1% of the population
they're probably going to be pretty
ticked off 1%
look at all the other people and how
happy you can make them you know he's so
if I look at the negative go back to it
because the top 1% my kind of jobs to
make a profit
yeah keeping this very very simple just
to illustrate what I do Tillett area
might do you can think about the things
Jim this is one of the things that can
be troubling about utilitarianism what
if we use this classroom and let's
pretend that we're all somewhat morally
depressed we enjoy we enjoy humiliating
and denigrating we don't like it
ourselves but you know if we could just
like pick one person in the class we'll
just pick one person and inflict a lot
of pain and a lot of humiliation and
that's going to feel good for us and
that is good for us individually as it
feels bad for that person it's gonna
feel really really bad for that but
there's
21:1 a boss only one of them you know
the happiness of majority or almost all
of it that way
military would say yes well I mean if
you look at it one person compared one
person to one person yeah then it may
not need cool out well then you'd say if
you have five people versus one person
but everybody's matched up with one
verse alone yeah you know might not work
out the same way
well but that's your utilitarian what
you do is you want to look at everybody
so if you actually had five people you
know the community of five and one of
them the other for a pleasure because of
a certain reaction and those pleasures
of the way that paint put it in those
pleasures together adding them up that
it's okay to do it but if it was the
right thing to do that should be a
little trouble now Bentham actually does
have ways of talking about that getting
around but now notice this is in fact a
way in which we will often do make moral
decisions don't aren't a lot of
government decisions made on the sort of
basis you look at everybody who's
affected then you try to make it overall
the best thing it may be be after some
people but overall it increases the net
can be that's the aggregate don't
businesses do this well they did
cost-benefit analysis
so this is a common mode of moral reason
that's the priority for study this is a
legitimate moral theory we're going to
look at some more Thursday we're gonna
look at how this affects how we evaluate
individuals when it comes to this and
then we're going to look at John Stuart
Mill and Italy have a few criticisms
with that Bentham puts everything on the
same level you could tally up all of
your pleasures and pains against each
other in order for Bentham system to
work that's one of the presuppositions
so I'll see all of you on Thursday